So let's look at the messaging complexity of the
mutual exclusion lock algorithm. The lock primitive, when a
process makes a lock request, it sends N minus
1 request messages. Because there are N nodes in
the distributed system, there are N minus 1 peers,
and so every node has to send a request
message to all its peers, so N minus 1
messages are the request messages sent out. And in response
to these request messages, every peer is going to
acknowledge a request message. So, they're going to be
N minus 1 messages traversing the network, which
are the acknowledgement message for this lock request. And
then, the process is happy using the lock
for the critical section. And it gets to
the unlock primitive, and the unlock primitive, once
again, we're going to send N minus 1 unlock
messages, through the unlock primitive and while sending a
unlock message to every one of the peers in the
distributive system, so N minus 1 messages are sent
over the network. Interesting thing that you notice is that
there's no acknowledgment for the unlock message because of
the assumption that we make that messages are never lost.
And therefore, when I send an unlock message, I
know that everybody will get it, everybody will remove my
request from the respective queues and go on with
life. And therefore there is no acknowledgment for that. And
so if you count the number of messages that are
involved and a lock plus unlock, totally, we have 3
to the N minus 1. That's the total number of
messages that are incurred, that is a message in complexity,
of the distributed mutual exclusion lock algorithm. That begs the
question, can we do better? And the answer is yes,
and the reason is going back to the condition that I said that is used
in making a decision as to whether I want the lock or not. If you recall, I
told you that the condition is, my request has to be at the top of the
queue, and second, I should have either gotten
acknowledgements for that request from everybody else, or I've
received a lock request from my peers that
have a time stamp that is later than my
own lock request. If the lock request that
I received from my peers have time stamps that
are later than mine, I know that they are going to wait for me to be served
before they're going to use the lock. And therefore,
what I can do if I am a receiving
node for a lock request, when I see a lock request, normally I would go ahead
and do an acknoweldgement. But, when I get
a lock request and I see, hey, this guy's
lock request is going to be after mine, so
I don't have to send an acknowledgement yet. What
I can do is wait til I'm actually
going to unlock. My unlock itself can serve as the
acknowledgement for that particular node that has
made a lock request that is later
in time than my own. So in other words, we can defer the acknowledgements if
my lock request precedes my peers lock
request. So we're combining the acknowledgement for
a lock request with the unlock. So if I do that, then I can bring
the message complexity down to 2 the N minus 1. So what we're doing is to gather
the acknowledgement messages if in fact our own
lock request is ahead of an incoming request that
I see from up here. That's how we
can reduce the messaging complexity of this algorithm to
be 2 to the N minus 1. By the
way, the distributed mutual exclusion lock problem have been
a fertile ground for researchers to think
about new algorithms that can shave the
messaging complexity even further from this 2 to the N minus 1, and I invite
you to look at the literature to see other works that have been done
to reduce the message complexity to even smaller numbers than 2 times N minus 1.